okay let's talk about Ted Cruz again
we've been talking about Ted Cruz a lot
because back in mid-december
I told you hey you know what Democrats
should target Ted Cruz in 2018 it might
be the perfect time to go after Ted
Cruz's Senate seat which is of course up
for re-election and now something like
nine months and then on January 25th
just a few days ago last week in fact no
earlier this week losing track of time
here it's so exciting no wait the 25th
was last week yeah yeah of course it was
I got to get a calendar I can't even
keep track of David Pakman show
calendars I should I know I should put
one up on the wall
last week Ted Cruz was leading
Democratic challenger Beto O'Rourke by
only eight points and with each passing
week or two the case for running hard
against Ted Cruz's Senate re-election
campaign gets even stronger we've now
learned that Beto O'Rourke has raised
more money than Ted Cruz in a quarter
for the second time in the last quarter
of 2017 Ted Cruz raised 1.9 million
dollars while his challenger Beto
O'Rourke raised 2.4 million dollars
about half a million dollars more than
incumbent Ted Cruz now the deficit that
O'Rourke is still facing is that Ted
Cruz in total has way more money Ted
Cruz has over seven million dollars or
Roarke has about four and a half million
but bet O'Rourke can keep closing the
gap if he can keep out raising Ted Cruz
month after month now as a reminder beto
or Roarke still hasn't even won his
primary Beddoes primary is on March 6 he
will likely win but we want to be sure
of that before we move on into general
election mode yes the odds are against a
Roarke in Texas but it's not impossible
the timing is arguably very good but
there is this problem that he needs to
take the overall money lead more than
likely because in general the candidate
with more money is the candidate that
wins name recognition continues to be a
problem for Beto or Roarke in the end
there's going to be a lot of less
enthusiastic voters who will
vote but they're probably just gonna
vote for whoever is the Republican on
the ticket Texas has more Republicans
than Democrats so in order to sort of
push back against that
Beto needs to raise his name recognition
and you know that that's an uphill
battle I know exactly how you do that I
think the name recognition is a big deal
I mean if he was running against John
Cornyn the other senator I think you
would have a better shot maybe she'll be
maybe they see Ted Cruz over in Texas as
their national hero
that's what represents the state so well
national hero born in Canada of course
but rational hero nonetheless yeah Ted
Ted Cruz on the one hand it it kind of
makes me feel a little sick but that
might be right that he's seen sort of as
a hero in Texas at the same time in
reality Ted Cruz is one of the most
dangerous ideologues in the Senate and
it should be one of the highest priority
takedown attempts and he happens to not
be hugely popular right now either in a
recent approval Gil Cruz had 19 percent
strong approval and 19 percent somewhat
approval meaning that 38 percent total
has any degree of approval of Ted Cruz
it's an uphill battle but it's a good
one and I hope people in the audience
will get involved yeah I think beta or
orc would make it would be wise if he
made an argument that Ted Cruz is really
only in it for himself you know he ran
for president as a freshman senator yep
I guess Obama did that too but Obama won
re-election run for president as a
freshman senator and win then it's much
harder to criticize you if you do what
Ted Cruz did and seem to be interested
like Trump and self-aggrandizement and
just fulfilling your greedy instincts
and then it's not as good of a look
that's for sure the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad